lobo la chine et la russie sont l'avancé
d'une offensive autoritaire contre un
ordre international fondé sur des règles
donc nous devons renforcer notre
dialogue et politique et notre
coopération pratique avec des
partenaires de même mentalité pour
promouvoir nos valeurs et protéger nos
intérêts je vais aussi proposé de
renforcer les activités de formation
dans et de renforcement des capacités
dans les pays partenaires dans notre
voisinage car la présence serait mieux
qu'à l'intervention nous devons aussi
prendre en compte les conséquences du
changement climatique je vais donc
proposer que l'otan doit établir à
l'étalon pour la réduction des émissions
émanant du secteur militaire pour
contribuer à l'objectif de zéro émission
carbone d'ici 2050 et conduire aussi une
évaluation annuelle sur la façon dont le
changement climatique que pourrait avoir
un impact sur nos troupes et nos
déploiements enfin je vais recommander
d'actualiser le concept stratégique de
l'otan pour évoquer ensemble
l'environnement stratégique en pleine
évolution pour nous réengager pour
défendre nos valeurs et aussi pour
renforcer le lien transatlantique il
s'agira du début de nos échanges sur le
temps horizon 2030 donc je me réjouis
d'entendre les opinions des ministres
alors que je préparais j'ai juste mes
propositions en vue du sommet jeudi
sinon nous évoquerons nos missions en
afghanistan et en irak
l'otan soutient pleinement le processus
de paix en afghanistan il s'agit de la
meilleure opportunité pour parvenir à
une solution politique durable et toutes
les parties doivent accélérer les
progrès pour saisir cette occasion
historique le temps à ajuster de façon
significative sa présence dans le cadre
de ce processus de paix toutefois les
négociations de paix demeure fragile
dès le niveau de violences demeure de
façon de très élevé de façon
inacceptable y compris des attaques des
talibans contre les civils
les talibans doivent réduire la violence
négocier en bonne foi et honorer les
engagements d'arrêter la coopération
avec des groupes terroristes
internationaux
notre objectif clair comme un éclair
l'afghanistan ne doit plus jamais être
un sanctuaire pour les terroristes pour
qu'ils puissent à attaquer nos pays donc
notre présence est basée sur des
conditions alors qu' aucun a lieu le
reste en afghanistan plus que nécessaire
nous ne partirons pas tant que le moment
ne soit pas opportun donc les ministres
vont continuer à évaluer la situation
sur le terrain et surveiller également
l'évolution de la situation de façon
très étroite
nous allons continuer à assurer toutes
les mesures pour garantir toutes les
mesures pour assurer la sécurité de nos
forces et envisager toutes les mesures à
prendre de façon coordonnée
la mission de l'otan en europe est une
autre contribution clé contre un cadre
de la lutte internationale contre le
terrorisme je m'attends à ce que les
ministres donnent leur feu vert pour
augmenter la mission en irak avec plus
de personnel alliés disponibles aux
points activités de conseil de formation
pour renforcer les institutions de
sécurité dans le pays de la mission va
s'élargir de façon progressive en
fonction de l'évolution de la situation
et cela répond à une demande du globe
irakien et se fera en étroite
collaboration avec la coalition
internationale pour qu'ensemble nous
puissions nous assurer que l'état
islamique ne reviendra pas tout ce que
nous faisons est soutenue par un
meilleur partage du fardeau à travers
l'alliance
les ministres feront le point sur les
progrès en 2021 sera la 7ème année
consécutive d'augmentation des dépenses
de défense depuis 2014
les alliés européens et le canada ont
contribué
cent quatre-vingt dix milliards de
dollars cumulés en plus les dépenses de
défense 9 alliés doivent dépenser de
poissons de leur pib sur la défense et
24 alliés vont dépenser au moins 20 % de
leurs dépenses dans les investissements
dans l'équipement moderne c'est une
excellente nouvelle mais nous devons
maintenir cette dynamique et sur ce je
suis à votre disposition pour les
questions fast fashion
la première question thomass gooch que
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung
comment vous avez la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le secrétaire général
pensez vous que décision sera prise à la
ministérielle de défense sur la durée
pendant laquelle les troupes resteront
encore en afghanistan et selon toute
probabilité ils vont rester ses troupes
vont rester plus plus longtemps après le
30 avril alors pensez vous que les
talibans marqueront leur accord et est
ce que l'otan est prête à envoyer des
troupes supplémentaires au besoin pour
protéger les troupes déployées merci or
nos clientes d'un oncle ho chi minh je
ne vais pas préjuger des conclusions
sortiront de l'intérieur
la défense cette semaine et ce que nous
pouvons dire c'est que nous allons
continuer à coordonner nos activités
nous consulter concernant les activités
en la glissant et tous les alliés de
l'otan soutiennent le processus de paix
le processus est fragile vie à des
obstacles mais ce processus est la seule
façon de parvenir à une solution
politique durable en aghanistan et donc
toutes les parties doivent saisir cette
occasion historique pour négocier un bal
poids et mon message aux talibans et
qu'ils doivent réduire la violence
ils doivent négocier en bonne foi et ils
doivent honorer leurs engagements de ne
pas travailler avec ou de soutenir des
groupes terroristes internationaux tels
que al quaida nous allons suivre
l'évolution de la situation sur le
terrain en afghanistan
nous allons à des consultations étroites
entre alliés et la sécurité de nos
troupes et absolument essentiel et nous
allons prendre toutes les mesures pour
garantir cette sécurité aucun allié ne
veut rester dans laquelle sont plus que
nécessaires
mais en même temps nous devons souvenir
pourquoi nous sommes entrés en
aghanistan nous sommes entrés en
afghanistan pour empêcher que ce pays
devienne un sanctuaire une plate forme
de groupes terroristes internationaux
pour qu'ils puissent préparer des
attaques terroristes sur nos territoires
et c'est pour cela que nous sommes
présents depuis près de 20 ans et c'est
pour cela que nous félicitons qu'au
cours de ces dernières années nous avons
pu former les forces afghanes et leur
permettre d'être maintenant en première
ligne dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
et dans les efforts de stabilisation de
leur pays nous passons maintenant à
fredrik lyonnais holstein terrain
merci je voudrais le passé en revue vos
compositions autant 2030 lorsque vous
dites que à des choses sont déjà en
place il y a des conciles tu sais que ce
consultations étendues sur plein de
sujets alors comment est ce que vous
pourrez veiller à ce que cette
consultation se poursuivre à l'avenir et
comment atteindre et vous toutes ces
ambitieuses proposition à l'horizon de
dix ans par exemple il nous avons une
occasion unique pour ré énergisé pour
renforcer le lien transatlantique
il a une nouvelle administration ben
laden qui est fortement engagée pour les
le continent nord-américain à la râpe
travailler ensemble et il ya aussi
l'ordre du jour autant à horizon 2030 et
à le fait que nous sommes tous
confrontés à davantage de défis auxquels
nous pouvons que nous pouvons surmonter
que ensemble car aucun pays aucun
continent ne peut faire face à ces défis
seul
nous aurons un sommet plus tard cette
année et cela nous fournit l'occasion
d'ouvrir un nouveau chapitre dans les
liens transatlantiques dans la
coopération transatlantique mon l'agenda
pour le temps à donner trente et un
agenda ambitieux car je pense que nous
devons vraiment être ambitieux face à
tous ces défis face à toutes ces menaces
auxquelles nous sommes collectivement
confrontés
donc tout ce que nous pouvons faire pour
renforcer cette alliance sera importante
pour nous tous et plus il y aura des
consultations politiques plus nous y
parviendrons plus nous pouvons répondre
à cette proposition que je vais formuler
et proposer aux ministres et ensuite aux
chefs d'état et de gouvernement qui
seront l'un des plus grands l'année je
pense que l'otan doit élargir ses
consultations sur des sujets qui sont
importants pour notre sécurité mais qui
ne sont pas uniquement des sujets
purement militaire par exemple questions
économiques qui ont des retombées
sécuritaire
ce sont des sujets sur lesquels nous
devons mener des consultations la
technologie la résilience sont d un
sujet important pour notre sécurité et
sont des domaines où nous devons avoir
davantage de consultations entre nous je
pense que cela bénéficierait à tous si
nous pouvons consulter non seulement les
mises à la défense des affaires
étrangères le chef d'établissement comme
faisons habituellement mais aussi à
intégrer aussi les conseils de sécurité
nationaux les ministres de l'intérieur
pour élargir cette perspective de l'otan
et pour renforcer les consultations au
sein de l'alliance les consultations
plus large signifie aussi que nous
devons renforcer nos échanges et que nos
partenaires notamment lorsque nous
envisageons les retombées de l'émergence
de la chine et d'une rude si de plus en
plus déterminés donc pas reparlé
consulter travailler avec des
démocraties de même sensibilité que nous
fait partie du renforcement de nos
consultations et nos liens politiques au
sein de l'otan je suis optimiste car le
temps a démontré sa capacité à s'adapter
aux changements quand le monde évolue et
le temps doit encore se changer
maintenant et je pense que le temps sera
à la hauteur de ce défi la question
suivante londres pour la bbc johnson
bien merci merci monsieur le secrétaire
général je crois que l'objectif initial
de l'accord états unis talibans était
que toutes les troupes étrangères
quittent l'afghanistan en mai 2021
pensez vous que cela ne va pas se passer
et si cela ne se passe pas où en
sommes-nous avec le processus de paix
pourriez-vous encore réduire le
contingent des dix mille hommes mal
stationnés en afghanistan pour le moment
pourriez-vous faire baisser ce chiffre
merci vous avez raison que
dans l'accord américain de totalement
bleu date butoir est le 1er mai pour le
retrait de toutes les troupes
internationales les allées de l'otan ont
signé sur la corse qui était signé l'un
dernière j'étais à kaboul lorsque
l'accord a été signé mais nous nous
félicitons de cette initiative et
suscitant aussi du lancement d'un
dialogue et intérêts records entre les
différents partis en afghanistan et la
salle façon parvenir à une paix durable
on a besoin de faire en sorte que ce
processus soit conduit est mené par les
afghans ce pour cela que vous allez le
temps ont soutenu ce processus et nous
suivons de très près des négociations
internes gars comme je le dis je ne vais
pas préjuger de ce qui sortira de la
réunion des ministres de la défense
cette semaine mais ce que je peux dire
c'est que je demande rue le pagne
équilibre entre fait que nous devons
assurer que nous restons pas plus que
l'union faut ni partir trop tôt car nous
voulons pas arriver une situation où
aghanistan devienne un sauveteur est une
plateforme pour des groupes terroristes
internationaux alors que c'était la
raison initiale pour laquelle nous
sommes entrés en aghanistan initialement
pour empêcher cela nous allons revoir en
permanence le nombre des troupes sur
place la présence a été signifiée
significativement réduite au cours des
années une époque nous avions 130000
troupes en opérations de combat à une
époque maintenant il y en a dix mines
donc nettement moins qu'il y a ah non
pour des missions d'assistance conseil
et formation est la raison pour laquelle
nous pouvons être sur place avec ce
chiffre relativement limitée diminuent
et parce que justement nous avons pu
aider zagora renforcer leurs propres
capacités et les forces de sécurité
afghanes
de montrer en mettant des forces
professionnelle et dévouée à la pour
parvenir à la tâche de stabilisation de
leur pays aidés pour lutter contre les
forces russes
nous sommes engagés à continuer à
assister les forces d'al ghad et parler
du financement jusqu'en 2024 et aussi
par le biais de l'information
nous allons consulter coordonnées
décision ensemble et ce sur la base de
ce que nous avons déjà 10 ans ont calé à
savoir nous sommes entrés ensemble a
justement semblé lorsque le moment sera
opportun nous partirons en chine pour la
question suivante moustafa saouaf radio
free europe
merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
secrétaire général
quelle est votre priorité pour
l'afghanistan quitté au 1er mai selon
l'accord états unis talibans si c'est le
cas les talibans ont-ils respecter leurs
engagements au regard des attaques
terroristes sur base des accords de doha
notre priorité est reste que
l'afghanistan ne redevienne pas un
refuge pour les terroristes de tous
bords c'est la priorité depuis il ya
près de 20 ans lorsque nous sommes allés
en afghanistan pour la première fois ce
n'est pas uniquement important pour les
afghans mais aussi pour nous pour la
sécurité de nos citoyens dans nos pays
ils ce sont les attaques du 11 septembre
qui ont entraîné la mission otan en
afghanistan est notre priorité est reste
que l'afghanistan ne redevienne pas un
refuge au terrorisme international
évidemment au fil de notre présence en
afghanistan et bien nous constatons que
l'une des meilleures armes au contre le
terrorisme et le développement des
capacités locales des forces afghanes
sur le terrain plus nous donnons les
capacités aux forces afghanes a lutté
elle même contre le terrorisme à se
battre elles mêmes sur leur terrain
plus nous aidons à l'aboutissement de la
mission otan en afghanistan et c'est
pour cela que graduellement nous avons
réduit notre présence en afghanistan
dans le cadre du processus de paix
dessinée et je crois que vous aviez
encore une autre question une question
subsidiaire
oui les talibans ont-ils tenu leurs
engagements au niveau de la lutte contre
le terrorisme
ce que nous voyons c'est que les
talibans sont bel et bien responsable
des violences
nous voyons que qu'ils aient besoin pour
les talibans de faire plus pour tenir
leurs engagements notamment l'engagement
de rompre tout contact avec les
organisations terroristes de soutenir
les organisations terroristes qui
pourraient planifier et perpétrer des
attaques contre nous donc les talibans
continuent à utiliser la violence
ils doivent arrêter négocier de bonne
foi et faire en sorte de ne plus
soutenir les terroristes parce que le
peuple afghan appel elle appelle de ses
voeux la région aussi et les alliés de
l'otan également tout monde après appel
à la paix en afghanistan et la meilleure
manière d'y arriver c'est d'utiliser ces
pourparlers de paix qu'ils sont
actuellement à caux est d'avoir une
solution pacifique négociée durable pour
tout le peuple afghan steiner prochaine
question est-ce que vous m'entendez oui
analyse j'ai une question contre la
flotte agenda le temps qu'ils consacrent
à nos places en capacité personnelle
qui que les volants essentiellement dans
la zone un peu de temps à ce courrier
les perspectives pour déployer la gs au
dessus de la libye et ça serait que
provisoire et de ces morts qu'en est-il
à malines niger qui rencontrent aussi
des difficultés vos chantiers en
territoire du noir est ce que l'otan est
prévue en consultation avec ce pays
africain week-end g5 où il était doté de
500 sièges à l'avenir piste je suis
heureux d'annoncer aujourd'hui que ça
car le general motors a donc déclaré que
la force
autant de nouveaux aéronefs de
surveillance terrestre est disponible et
être en capacité opérationnelle ce sont
des drones de reconnaissance qui vont
nous permettre d'avoir des informations
des renseignements précieux pour
l'alliance alors j'ai vu rendu visite à
la base de signes ou de sigonella en
italie en sicile pour il faut voir ces
nouveaux équipements et le personnel qui
planche sur ce projet sont des experts
de haut vol capable d'utiliser
d'exploiter toutes les informations
collectées par cette pelote de
surveillance est donc vraiment
d'apporter un gros plus aux alliés et à
l'otan ces drones peuvent ont une
autonomie d'une trentaine d'heures et
donc ils peuvent couvrir l'ensemble de
la zone euro atlantique du grand nord au
sahel du moyen-orient à l'atlantique et
avec ses drones nous pouvons surveiller
la région vaincre et nous permettront
des airs de surveiller
les mouvements sur le terrain à tout
moment ils peuvent même identifié au sol
des engins explosifs improvisés ils sont
donc essentielles pour fournir des
informations des renseignements est
repéré des éléments alors bien sûr ils
viendront en soutien des activités mais
je pense que la plupart des vols seront
au dessus de la frontière est et sud de
l'alliance ces drones sont essentielles
c'est une capacité de surveillance et de
réponse à toute crise qui viendrait à
intervenir nous pouvons donc les
déployer en mission c'est l'opération de
l'otan mais bien sûr pour ce faire nous
avons besoin d'une décision de
déploiement prises par les alliés pour
les affecter à des missions et
opérations hors du territoire de l'otan
mais mais les vols le long de la
frontière pour fournir des informations
précieuses sur ce qu'il se passe à nos
frontières est autorisé et yann marquer
prochaine question visionnement quai de
france cuse beaucoup la conférence de
presse à ma question porte sur les
investissements dans des criques
indigènes argenté de rupture
pouvez vous me dire dans quelle mesure
ces une augmentation de ses
investissements en partie que vous
échangez avec émises la défense cette
semaine
est ce que vous envisagez plus
d'investissements dans la normalisation
naturalité des programmes conjoints dans
l'alliance et grands est ce que nous
allons voir à cadres tant pour ses
technologies émergentes et de rupture
les eaux dt du protoss et les
sont essentiels pour l'otan et pour les
alliés pour nombre de ces technologies
sont des technologies double utilisation
à des fins civiles
d'une part et militaires d'autre part il
faut donc veiller à pouvoir maintenir
cet avantage technologique que nous
avons
en veillant investir aussi dans les
technologies émergentes et de rupture je
pense par exemple à l'intelligence
artificielle à l'informatique quantique
à la reconnaissance faciale au système
autonome et surtout si donc combine
toutes ces technologies et bien les
produits qui en ressortiront un impact
sérieux changeront la nature de la
guerre et la manière dont nous allons
mener nos différentes activités
militaires alors c'est quelque chose que
nous faisons déjà bien sûr mais ce que
nous devons sait tenir la cadence et
c'est pour cela que je salue le fait que
les alliés de l'otan investissent plus
dans ces technologies émergentes et de
rupture le fait que nous soyons en
mesure d'augmenter les dépenses de
défense aux quatre coins de l'alliance
et que 20% de cette augmentation des
dépenses de défense soit investi dans
des technologies novatrices nous permet
de développer des technologies de pointe
avec des applications militaires par
exemple les drones dont on vient de
parler les drones à gs ces aéronefs de
surveillance du terrain nous permettent
d'utiliser des technologies de rupture
pour être vraiment des appareillages de
dernier cri et nous fournir les
informations les plus précieuses qu'ils
soient donc nous avons besoin du
meilleur du meilleur
les alliés s'acquittent de ce
développement mais nous devons maintenir
cet avantage technologique et deuxième
élément il faut empêcher qu'il y ait des
écarts technologiques entre les alliés
bien sûr je salue le fait que les alliés
investissent plus dans les nouvelles
technologies
mais quand différents alliés ont des
capacités de plus en plus avancé des
drones des aéronefs des
navires des décharges qu'il n'y a pas
d'écart technologiques qu'ils puissent
communiquer entre eux ces nouveaux
équipements donc l'interopérabilité la
communication entre tous ces équipements
à des tours était très importante pour
l'otan mais plus important que jamais
aujourd'hui pour devenir la norme et
faire en sorte que nos forces soit
interopérable aussi lorsqu'elles sont
confrontées à des technologies
émergentes et de rupture et enfin je
suis fermement convaincu par le fait que
l'otan peut être une plate forme pour
aborder les questions éthiques qui sont
liés à ces technologies et développer
des normes lignes directrices sur
l'aspect plus éthique de ces
technologies est une toute dernière
chose
je crois que ces technologies peuvent
aussi nous permettre de développer des
travaux avec le secteur privé et de
lancer par exemple des start up
alors que nous renforçons encore nos
investissements en matière de
technologies émergentes et de rupture et
voilà donc ce que je veux dire lorsque
nous dit jeudi que nous avons besoin
d'une initiative autant pour
l'innovation c'est mettre ensemble
toutes nos ressources travailler de
concert pour être en mesure à la fois de
développer ces technologies mais aussi
pour les utiliser de manière qui nous
permettent de travailler véritablement
ensemble bref tweed pour la prochaine
fois que je laisse la question quel
autre canadien points d'interconnexion
bien en deçà de vega et la question et
votre proposition il pourrait viser le
partage du fardeau dont le cadre des
efforts tant l'otan de les trente vise à
augmenter les budgets militaires de
façon substantielle est ce que vous
pouvez donner des chiffres sur l'impact
budgétaire que cela aurait encore le
pourcentage quelles seraient les allées
qui paraît davantage - et quelles
seraient les conséquences pour un pays
comme la norvège est aujourd'hui la
manière dont l'otan produit des
capacités militaires la police du ciel
les groupements tactiques les forces
navales permanente et financé de la
manière suivante les pays qui apportent
les capacités apporte aussi le
financement de ses capacités donc s'il
vous envoyer des troupes au groupement
tactique autant en lituanie comme c'est
le cas de lavage et bien c'est la
norvège qui payent la facture
je crois que nous devons changer la
donne
l'otan contribuerait à couvrir ses coûts
simplement parce que si l'on paye plus
ensemble l'on démontre aussi plus
ensemble
l'engagement à l'article 5 à la
dissuasion et à la défense et cela vient
renforcer notre unité politique et notre
cohésion
notre unité politique elle est fondée
sur notre engagement à gauche défendre
les uns les autres
deuxièmement je pense que si nous avons
un financement autant pour certaines de
ses activités les groupements tactiques
les exercices la police du ciel
et bien cela voudra dire que nous
donnerons aussi des des incidents aux
alliés à apporter plus dans cette
escarcelle capacitaire pour faire en
sorte que les alliés contribuent à
hauteur à toutes ces activités de
dissuasion et de défense et
troisièmement je pense que cela
permettra un meilleur partage de la
charge du fardeau au sein de l'alliance
parce qu'il est injuste que les pays qui
font apport de troupes d'aéronefs de
navires pour les activités de défense
paye en plus toute la facture de ses
troupes de ses navires etc
donc si l'on paye plus ensemble au titre
du budget autant ce sera une
distribution plus juste des coûts une
répartition plus juste de la charge au
sein de l'alliance
c'est important également parce que le
partage de la charge
c'est aussi cet objectif de 2% de plus
et les allées rencontre cet objectif de
2% d'augmentation de dépenses de défense
on a vu des progrès significatifs il
faut que ça se poursuivre mais le
partage de la charge c'est aussi les
contributions l'apport à l'otan et ma
proposition a pour but que l'on ait un
partage équitable de la charge pas
uniquement en deniers sonnants et
trébuchants
mais aussi en force force pour notre
dissuasion et notre défense pour faire
montre
que nous croyons la défense collective
peines allant d'une prochaine chronique
venture à l'ombre de jane's vous ne
pouvez pas vous entendre ce que je
m'entendais oui c'est bon maintenant
très bien merci de me donner cette
cloison de vous poser une question
j'avais une question sur vos rapports
avec l'administration bayh dole et
quelles sont vos attentes concernant la
différence que vous avez pu constater au
cours des quatre dernières années 15 h
et comment est-ce que cela va avoir un
impact sur la politique de l'otan au
cours des quatre prochaines années
quelles sont les politiques qui vont
continuer beaucoup s'attendaient à ce
que le tram se retire de l'otan je vais
gagner un deuxième mandat et d'après un
documentaire de la bbc diffusé la
semaine dernière le président trump
était sur le point il annoncé ce retrait
des états unis l'otan lors du sommet de
2018 est ce qu'on pouvait de confirmer
et concernant les sommets est ce que
vous pouvez nous donner une date plus
précise sur le sommeil mais ce que sera
le mois prochain
je pense que c'est un secret de
politiques chez coco des dernières
cadres ne venait il ya eu des débats
difficiles au sein de l'otan dans le
temps le projetant vers l'avenir et
l'avenir c'est que il ya une
administration
aux etats unis à washington qui est
fermement engagée aux liens
transatlantiques à l'otan et au
renforcement du lien entre l'europe et
les états unis
je m'en félicite j'ai parlé à deux
reprises avec le président présent
partout depuis son élection et à chaque
fois il a été très clair sur
l'importance de renforcer nos adhérents
c'est de renforcer le temps et mes
propositions pour l'otan à horizon 2030
vise justement à parvenir à cet objectif
pour pouvoir ouvrir un nouveau chapitre
dans les relations transatlantiques
je me réjouis de pouvoir accueillir à
bientôt le niçois aux tonneaux des
ministres le défensif à bruxelles entre
une réunion virtuelle et lorsque j'ai pu
lui parler il a envoyé le même message
de soutien l'otan et de soutien
renforcement de la collaboration entre
l'automne et le continent américain et
européen et même chose de la part de
talibés comme le secrétaire d'état nous
savons très bien que le président bart
hayden connaît très bien la langue le
temps il a participé à des réunions de
l'otan dans ses précédentes fonctions
j'ai eu le privilège d'être avec lui
dans le passé et je me réjouis de
l'accueillir prochainement c'est que
tous les autres dirigeants de
l'organisation lors de notre sommeil qui
est un de l'année donc nous avons
maintenant l'occasion de reconstruire
notre alliance et je me réjouis d'y
parvenir prochainement ensemble et la
question suivante
wi-lan hamas a dit nous vous entendons
oui merci beaucoup merci pour cette
conférence de presse
et je l'espère pour deux journées deux
ministériel de défense qui est de le
rendre de bons résultats pour
l'afghanistan
ma question est la suivante
l'administration byden décidera tel de
sortir de l'accord us talibans si c'est
le cas que ferez vous est-ce que vous
maintiendrez la mission après deux
décennies parce que en l'an 2000 il n'y
avait que deux groupes terroristes il y
à plus de 20 groupes insurgés
terroristes en afghanistan aujourd'hui
qu'en sera-t-il donc de l'avenir de la
mission
oui ou non aux as nous allons évaluer la
situation
nous allons suivre de près l'évolution
de la situation sur le terrain pour
pouvoir mesurer dans quelle mesure les
talibans respecte nos engagements des
engagements qu'elles ont signés dans le
cadre d'un accord entre les talibans et
les états unis
ce qui est important c'est que nous
puissions travailler collectivement
ensemble et le qatar ont ainsi que d
autres représentants américaine ont
clairement indiqué que c'est mon
procéder à ces évaluations des analyses
et qu'ils mèneront des trois de
consultations avec les alliés et nous
prendrons ensemble cette décision
concernant l'avenir de la présence de
l'otan en afghanistan
une des questions que nous devons suivre
de très près portent notamment sur la
conformité
c'est ça ta vis-à-vis de cet accord
d'étalement de réduire niveau de
violence des gossip en bonne foi et
respecté des promesses qu'ils ont fait
dans cet accord de ne pas soutenir des
groupes terroristes qui organisent des
attaques terroristes contre mon pays
donc je ne peux pas préjuger de ce qui
sera se dit d'un ton mystérieux de cette
semaine mais je peux vous dire que ces
décisions seront prises collectivement
et
nous analyserons ensemble l'impression à
adopter en afghanistan par la suite il
ya beaucoup de problèmes en afghanistan
d'autres groupes de terroristes nous
voyons que l'état islamique et 16 de
s'implanter en afghanistan mais en tout
cas par rapport à où par rapport à ce
que tu es la situation avant
l'intervention de l'otan l'afghanistan
n'est plus dirigé par d'état des morts
n'est plus un pays où des groupes de
bruxelles quelques indiens peuvent
s'organiser librement s'entraîner aux
caisses de financement pour préparer des
attaques contre nous mais au moins nous
devons pas me font parvenir à cet
objectif mais aussi nous avons pu
soutenir des progrès socio-économiques
en afghanistan il ya cinq ans médiatique
très dynamique
il ya des femmes qui disposent de droits
dont elle ne disposait pas préalablement
et nous avons pu aussi observer le
développement des forces de sécurité
afghanes beaucoup plus professionnel et
ce notamment grâce au soutien de pays
membres de l'otan donc et des progrès
significatifs et nous devons nous
assurer que ces progrès ne seront pas
fragiliser alors que nous allons prendre
nos décisions
comment ça teri shields npr allez-y
terry merci juste toujours pour rebondir
sur l'afghanistan
monsieur le secrétaire général vous
souhaitiez qu'une décision soit prise à
la ministérielle de défense
rester ou partir en tout cas des
orientations solide
alors évidemment vu que la question est
à l'étude au sein de l'administration
byden ce ne sera pas le cas en concluez
vous que
date du 1er mai est exclu pour le
retrait des troupes américaines et des
troupes internationales
vous auriez aimé le savoir tout de suite
et que pensez vous du groupe d'étude sur
l'afghanistan qui dit qu'il faut qu'il y
ait des négociations immédiatement
lancée pour étendre ce délai et pour que
les troupes soient où le contingent soit
accrue
est ce que si cela est demandé l'otan
sera présent et répondra présente et
s'agissant des femmes
vous venez de mentionner les réussites
de la société civile la société civile
et les femmes sont extrêmement inquiets
du fait que si vous ne suivez pas tout
cela sera perdu qu'on se frotte oui bien
entendu j'entends appel de la émanant de
la part de nombreux afghans sur
l'importance de ne pas fragiliser des
acquis que nous avons pu obtenir en
afghanistan à la fois dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme mais aussi dans le
domaine social et économique et les
progrès qui ont pu être réalisés
notamment pour les femmes
c'est pour cela que nous devons prendre
ces décisions très importantes ensemble
analysé ensemble et des de très près les
différentes options et nous devons
préparer aux différentes options
différents scénarios et les envisager de
façon coordonnée entre alliés la réunion
des ministres de la défense plus tard
cette semaine sera bien entendu
importante et l'afghanistan sera à
l'ordre du jour
mais pouvons aussi mener ces
consultations l'otan sans la présence
des ministres car nous avons des
consultations régularité au siège pour
des consultations directement avec les
différentes capitales et si nécessaire
nous pouvons convoqué avec un court
préavis une réunion des ministres
surtout quand même états de la région
sont maintenant ouvertes donc le
prendront ces décisions ensemble et nous
prendrons la décision lorsque nous
pensons que le moment est arrivé et sur
la base de toutes les informations que
tous les alliés pour le fournier surtout
les états unis vu qu aux etats unis sont
le pays qui dispose de plus de troupes
et de capacité en capacité présent
l'aghanistan
mais comme vous le savez la majorité des
troupes de l'otan l'afghanistan ne sont
pas des troupes américaines mais
viennent de pays partenaires et de pays
européens donc cela démontre la présence
de l'autre en afghanistan et va au delà
des états unis il s'agit d'étudier des
alliés des partenaires et démontre
l'importance pour les états unis d'avoir
29 a dit à ses côtés et des partenaires
de travailler avec eux notamment pour
répondre aux défis auxquels nous sommes
confrontés en magasin coop et pour la
toute dernière question nous allons au
canada guy berthiaume a canadian press
merci beaucoup merci pour cette
conférence de presse je voudrais revenir
au partage de la charge et l'importance
du partage de cette charge
c'est vrai que le canada doit encore
développer un plan pour atteindre cet
objectif de 2%
qui dit et pourtant dit que ce n'est pas
un étalon de mesure unique il faudrait
aborder d'autres éléments
c'est vrai que
y at il des pourparlers pour changer
l'instrument de mesure des 2% pour le
partage du fardeau
et craignez vous les progrès qui sont
réalisés sur l'alliance à cause de ce
partage de la charge étant donné le
déséquilibre entre certains pays je
pense que certains alliés mettent en
oeuvre ce qui a été entérinée en 2014 et
je pense que tous les alliés souhaitent
augmenter leurs dépenses de défense et
nous avons fixé cet objectif des 2 % du
pib et tous les alliés ont commencé à
relever ce chiffre après des années de
coupes budgétaires dans les budgets
défense depuis 2014 tous les alliés
voient ce budget à la hausse
alors il ya une différence entre des
coupes de plusieurs milliards par an est
graduellement une d'une progressive ray
augmentation et ses 190 milliards de
dollars supplémentaires europe et canada
et le canada n'a pas manqué à l'appel le
canada a également augmenté ses dépenses
de défense nous l'avons vu nous pensons
d'ailleurs je pense que cela va se
poursuivre mais j'insiste le juste
partage du fardeau ce n'est pas
uniquement des liquidités ce sont des
contributions et nous voyons combien le
canada contribue à la défense collective
de l'europe le canada est à la tête de
l'un des groupements tactiques présent
dans les pays baltes en lettonie pour ne
pas la citer
je me suis rendu et j'ai vu le
professionnalisme et l'engagement des
forces canadiennes et et cela démontre
vraiment l'unité transatlantiques et la
manière dont les troupes canadiennes
sont prêtes au combat pour défendre la
partie orientale de l'alliance dans la
zone de la baltique et avec ma
proposition au titre de l'agenda autant
2030 jeu reconnaît ses contributions là
aussi
parce que je pense qu'il n'est que
judicieux qu'un pays qui déploie des
troupes n'est pas en supporter tous les
frais et que l'otan puisse financer en
commun une plus grande partie de ses
frais de déploiement et c'est pour cela
que je propose que l'on augmente le
financement pour la dissuasion et la
défense pour les activités de dissuasion
et de défense comme par exemple le
groupement tactique canadien au titre du
budget autant parce que pour le moment
nous avons un système qui est que les
pays qui contributeurs de troupes sont
également contributeur financier il
n'est que juste que les pays
contributeurs de troupes voit une partie
des frais engagés remboursées au titre
du budget autant alors le partage du
fardeau c'est 2 % certes mais c'est
aussi les contributions capacitaire en
nature et je sais que le canada
contribue lourdement à nos missions et
opérations et aux activités de défense
collective en europe
merci merci à tous de nous avoir
rejoints ceci met un terme à notre
conférence de presse rendez-vous
virtuellement dans la semaine pour la
ministérielle de défense merci